all right you guys this is it this is my
finished product isn't that crazy
i'm just kidding this is an actual
sponge hey guys this is inka
and today i'm gonna be making the
amazing
edible dish sponge cake so i know the
concept
in itself sounds a little bit crazy but
with the everything is cake phenomenon
that's been happening lately where
literally
everything is cake i guess i shouldn't
be too surprised that there is also a
dish sponge
that is actually cake i actually first
heard about this cake when one of you
sent me a message on instagram and i
just remember being so completely blown
away by
how much it looks like an actual dish
sponge like literally
like this and when i did a poll asking
you guys if i should make it
most of you said yes and that is why i
am here today
to make it happen so i know that emma
from emma's goodies and emmy from emmy
made in japan have done this cake before
emma even came up with this lovely lemon
cake
recipe that i think looks so good but
after doing summer research i found out
that the first person who actually
invented and created this edible dish
bunch cake concept
is actually a pastry chef from the uk
who's also known
as a food illusionist so i decided to
give him a call
and ask him all about how he first came
up with this hi my name's ben churchill
known as the food illusionist i've been
creating food illusions online i've been
doing mainly sort of more
traditional like mirror glazed apples
beetroot cakes a lot of tv and videos
things like that i thought why don't i
make something that looks so unappealing
to people so disgusting
but hide some nice flavors in there so i
thought why not do a sponge in on the
word of a sponge as
sponge cake that kind of reminds me of
how there's that everything is cake
phenomenon that's happening right now
what do you think about that i think
it's great that it's it's highlighting
all this art that's going on
it's enabling people to push the
boundaries you know people are thinking
outside the box could you also maybe run
me through the process of how you make
this sponge cake the main body of the
sponge is an olive oil cake got a bit of
food coloring in
green food coloring that's for the
scrubby bit it doesn't matter what that
looks like because that's going to get
crumbled up you don't lose any of the
flavor if anything it gives you a
different texture of cake
foam made out of lemon juice you can't
tell it from normal washing up foam you
know i mean it's so realistic and then
it's finished off with an apple puree
it's drizzled over for little washed up
liquid itself and just do a bit of a
scratching on the top it depends what
look you're going for if you want to use
sponge you do that if you want a fresh
sponge you just keep it nice and flat
since i'm going to be trying to recreate
this
sponge cake at home and i also want you
know other people to be able to recreate
this
do you have any tips for us it's just
taking your time a bit really don't
sweat over the things that are going to
come together
in the big picture enjoy it as much as
they can you think that i'll be able to
make it no problem
you'll have fun with it definitely i
hope so anyway i'm actually
really really excited about making this
happen food illusions are just so cool
for the most part i will be following
chef ben's recipe
it's going to be an olive oil cake an
apple puree dish soap situation for the
soapy foam part i'm gonna be following
emma's meringue based recipe all right
with that said
let's get to making the cake batter in
my bowl here i'm gonna just crack in
four eggs really quickly i'm just gonna
go ahead and add in the sugar quite a
bit of sugar but
we're trying to make a dish sponge
edible and tasty so i guess more sugar
is a good thing just whisk it together
that is looking pretty good the next
step is actually to add in your olive
oil and the trick
to making a really good olive oil cake
is actually
to buy really good olive oil so i
basically went out and bought the
fanciest olive oil i could find the
olive oil is essentially
substituting your butter
smells really good i'm gonna add in some
flour as well all of it
some baking powder mix that in together
carefully i'm also going to add in a
little bit of vanilla
and of course lemon zest i'm getting
this like
sticky viscous batter and what i'm going
to do is actually separate some of it
out
so i can dye one part yellow and one
part green so i'm just pouring a little
bit
i'm going to add some lime zest to the
green cake batter
now for the fun part of dyeing the cake
batter
just gonna add that right in just to
make sure that it actually comes out a
more vibrant yellow
oh am i gonna get green i think this is
good to go
my yellow and my green i'm gonna put
them into two separate cake pans
beautiful yellow color gently smoothing
it out
a little bit green cake is going in
this one doesn't have to be as perfect i
am going to go ahead and pop these in
the oven
so now i'm just going to let it bake and
cool and in the meantime i am going to
work on the apple puree
dish soap which sounds again super
bizarre but is
very interesting and i start off with my
lemon juice and i'm gonna add my sugar
good amount of sugar some diced apples
i'm also going to add in some baked
apples
since the one that chef ben did was
actually a baked apple puree i start
blitzing everything
once it looks like this i'm gonna add in
my green food coloring
the classic color of dish soap
okay this is my dish soap over here my
cakes have cooled
the yellow one is this big yellow pillow
and the green looks kind of grimy and
you know like like a sponge which i
guess is kind of the point let's start
off by
trimming the yellow that looks like a
pretty spongy yellow
cutting these sides trim off the top and
the bottom
lining it up to make sure they're
exactly the same
size i promise this is a clean sponge
trim this part off this texture is
already like kind of really spongy
looking in a kitchen sponge kind of way
i'm gonna put these aside
oh my god i almost threw my sponge cake
in the kitchen stick because i thought
it was
an actual sponge so here's what the
green one looks like right now these
brown bits kind of just look like
dirty bits on a sponge i'm gonna go with
chef ben's method
of crumbling up his green cake so we can
essentially
pile it up on the yellow cake i have all
my crumbled green cake here
honestly look a little bit like moss
right now and then i also have my sponge
if i have the two parts ready i'm just
gonna scoop
my little green bits on top press it
down like so
so it almost looks like a used sponge
this also helps make sure that it's just
a thin layer
it doesn't have to be perfect because
sponges are not
perfect either your final press this
is what i have right now and it looks
insane it actually looks like a sponge
this
is crazy so this is one of the ones i
have that's used right
i am going to now plate it up really
quick with my detergent
and also whip up some foam making the
foam is fairly easy i'm using some
pasteurized egg whites two tablespoons
of sugar
and a little bit of lemon juice splash
of vanilla
now i can go ahead and whip it up we're
just trying to get it foamy
that's already looking very dish liquidy
i'm going to now
pull my cake back in here so i'm going
to go ahead and add some foam on top i'm
just gonna drop it right on there
that looks like actual foam that's my
dish soap that is
actually crazy this is crazy look at
this foam it is so
realistic actually looks like a really
soapy kitchen sponge i am truly
in all i don't know if this is a bad
thing to say but it really just looks
both amazing and disgusting at the same
time which
looks like somebody left a used sponge
on a plate the title of my dish sponge
cake
it is time to get a new sponge so for
comparison purposes can you tell which
one is real and which one is fake
this is insane i truly think that this
is so fun
the idea of like making something look
like what it isn't
sending a picture to chef ben to see if
he approves
and he approves yes but the real test of
course too is also to actually make sure
that it is enjoyable i'm going to take a
little bit of that
this texture even feels like foam
cut right in here
it really just tastes like olive oil
cake with a bit of the apple sweetness
and a little bit of lemon
but i really do think the biggest draw
here is be able to tell somebody that
you ate
a dish sponge this was super fun thank
you guys so much
for suggesting that i give this a try i
hope you guys enjoy this video
that you give this a shot to and i will
see you guys soon
[Music]
bye
you